and yes thank you
good morning everybody and welcome to
this latest meeting of the traffic
covered 19 public engagement board
um thank you for your attendance i have
apologies today from councillor welton
and andrew latham from
healthwatch trafford
excuse me are there any declarations of
interest
in today's me are gender items
i don't see any the minutes of the last
meeting the meeting was held on the 17th
of december can i thank george devlin
for chairing that meeting in my absence
and can we take the minutes as read and
a true and accurate record
thank you um
so we'll swiftly move on then to the uh
the the update for trafford on the
pandemic and today i'm going to ask
julia
burgess allen to stand in for helen and
of course jill we've now got this new
variant with us so i'm sure there's lots
of information to be given out over to
you thank you
thank you very much chair um so the
situation in trafford at the moment is
that our rate is continuing to increase
um and
we're currently seeing around 140 cases
per day our
rate is at
417 100 000
um and uh we are tracking upwards but in
line with the england average um we're
slightly below the england average but
um on a similar trajectory and in terms
of how we're looking in comparison with
the rest of greater manchester um we
currently have the second highest rate
in greater manchester and that's sort of
where we've been fluctuating with you
know in that top three or four um
since we came down from the spike that
we had earlier in the autumn
um so um
somewhat of a concerning uh picture for
that reason
um and we've got a spread of cases
across the borough
so it's not especially concentrated
in one particular area
at the moment
higher highest rates are in the wards of
priory
brooklyn and also in davie hume
west
and
thinking about the the age groups
um our
relatively high rates of community
transmission at the moment are being
driven um by school-aged children
particularly the the naught 14s
and the good news is that the rates are
not increasing in the over 60s in fact
they're tracking slightly downwards
so obviously that's the age group we're
most worried about so so that's good
news
the other um good news is that the
covid admissions to hospital of trafford
residents continue to
gradually decline at this time
so
let's see we
there were 114 admissions during the
week ending the 21st of november
and that compares to 130 in the previous
week
in terms of mortality that's also
declining at the moment so it's that
interesting picture of increasing
rates while we're having a reduction in
hospital admissions
and deaths that very much points of
course to the effectiveness of our
vaccination program
and as you mentioned um at the beginning
their chair we obviously have this
recent development of
the new variant omicron
first detected in southern africa and
obviously we've now detected a number of
cases of the new variant um globally and
indeed in england
and i can confirm that there are no
cases of omicron in trafford at this
time
and as you would imagine um there's
incredibly intensive surveillance um and
we're paying attention to uh all of the
data and doing um
a sequencing to make sure that if there
are any cases if and when
they occur we're able to to pick those
up and obviously the government have
responded in a precautionary and swift
manner to the emergence of this variant
and what that means uh for us in
trafford i think is
we also want to take a similar
precautionary approach um
we are um uh now in the cold period of
the year um
not out in in the open as much as we
were spending more time in enclosed into
all spaces so it's obviously sensible um
for us
to
where we can revert to some of those
measures that we all know very well but
we know work um in terms of putting on a
face covering um just maintaining that
social distancing um and you know
keeping our hands clean keeping uh rooms
uh and indoor spaces ventilated um these
are the things that work we know they're
effective and of course vaccination
which is our most effective tool in our
toolkit against um
against covid and
while we are still discovering and
trying to understand um what uh the new
variant will mean for us uh in trafford
in england and globally um it's simply
sensible for us to be a little cautious
at this time
and so there's no
there's no strong evidence at all to
suggest
that
the new variant
can escape the vaccine but we do know
that there are a number of mutations so
we're building that evidence and as soon
as we know more um we'll be able to
respond but at this time and there's uh
every indication that uh you know the
vaccines that we have will continue to
be effective and we've got a really
strong message i think to get out around
ensuring that anyone who has not yet
come forward for their first dose or
indeed uh their second or are eligible
for
um the booster and haven't yet come
forward for it to do so now would be a
really sensible time to do so so i think
that in summary is um the epidemiology
and just a bit of an overview of the the
situation with with the new variant and
i'll pause there chair
thank you general and before the
questions i do actually uh uh
recognize the government have now
introduced monetary face mask wearing on
public transport and closed spaces and
shops and i think that is welcome and
and it just highlights the fact that six
weeks ago in trafford we advised schools
to do this and and
i suppose it's where trafford leads the
government are now following in that
case
um i'll hand over questions i've got a
question from councillor new grosh
hello i
my apologies i did lose a little bit of
connection during that presentation did
we get the positivity rate the
percentage of positive tests
that's my question can i ask what
percentages
yeah no i didn't give you that just bear
with um let me have a look
sorry i don't have that to hand um i'll
i'll be able to dig it out for you and
give it to you later in the meeting
apologies thank you appreciate it
i actually thought uh
counselor new grocer that information
was in the report that was provided uh
with the documents i think it's around
about is our positivity rate around
about 10
or something like that compared to uh uh
the rest of the country
yes i think that's right but let me get
the right figure for you and then i'll
i'll be able to report that just bear
with
i'll come back to you with it thank you
uh are there any further questions at
all for uh for gila
uh judith do you want to come in
council lloyd no
i don't see anything we can come back to
that then uh
oh yeah
10.5 percent thank you 10.5 percent to
account for the new gross
um so moving on then uh mass testing uh
well welcome ben mill wilmot ben
thanks very much chair um so i guess the
key update today in terms of we've been
continuing to monitor outbreaks and
sending our testing team to carry out
testing in order to find asymptomatic
people so as an example yesterday we
sent a mobile test unit into a school to
test parents and carers staff and pupils
we ended up doing 101 tests in the end
and considering that was a small school
we're really pleased with those numbers
and we also continue to hand that larger
flow test to organizations of business
just to encourage regular testing for
example in the past fortnight we've
given tests out to nurseries and other
businesses
so our key messaging now on unlocked to
flow testing um is still to test
regularly but what we're really
emphasizing is that you should plan
ahead and make tests in a part of a pain
to go on about so there are a number of
circumstances where we'd really
recommend using electro flow tests so
that's before going to places that i
like to be busy
before visiting someone who's at a
higher risk of getting seriously ill
from covered uh twice a week if your
work requires you to do so and again
twice a week if you or your child's
school college university requires you
to do so
i'm obviously just to kind of really
re-emphasize that we encourage people to
do that because we know there are still
around one in three people with covert
who don't have any symptoms so it is
still really really important to go and
do so
and finally i know i say this on a
regular basis but it's still worth
re-emphasizing especially at this time
of year when we know that um that during
winter lots can be going around if you
have any kind of covert symptoms
whatsoever please create yourself a pcr
test um it may well be that it's
something else but just be on the safe
side we're really really encouraging you
especially this time to go out and get a
pcr test for kills all those symptoms so
that's that's my key messages for today
thanks very much
thank you ben i have any questions at
all for ben on testing
yeah judith have you got a question
um yeah
and
obviously testing is really important
but we seem to get
a bit mixed messages because this is the
kind of social seasoning season as well
for people to going out to parties and
stuff like that
and i mean are you encouraging people
who are going out and socializing to
take lateral flow tests at least before
they go out
we're absolutely encouraging that so
yeah absolutely as a minimum before you
go out and about and we know that
there's going to be much more events
happening now christmas parties etc so
yes um key key message as an absolute
minimum before you go out and about um
especially if you're going to be seeing
people that you wouldn't normally see um
please please please yes go and take a
lecture flow test before those you do
that absolutely
uh thank you uh ben i actually council
lloyd i did hear our health secretary
savage avid on the
radio this morning and whilst they're
not cancelling christmas he actually did
encourage people to actually take flow
tests before they go out socializing
that's the compromised position that
they've they've probably arrived at
are there any further questions at all
i don't see any cursed kirstie's not
joined as jilla but do you want to give
us anything you've done on contact uh
tracing and outbreak management
thank you has been in touch and she is
in an outbreak meeting at the moment but
she's hoping to join us when that ends
well we could just put that item back on
the agenda absolutely she'll be with us
shortly that's great we'll do we'll do
that um so we'll move on to mass
vaccination and rebecca domain rebecca
um
there's quite a lot probably here for
you today um
we've got the prime minister saying that
we're going to have vaccination uh hubs
popping up like christmas trees and i'm
sure that there's a lot of anxious
whereas now they've expanded the booster
program to over 18s there'll be a lot of
anxious residents across trafford
wanting to book but clearly if you do
try and book it's now still sells you
onto the system you can't book so
perhaps you could you could talk us all
through that and the advice to residents
from the ccg and traffic in terms of
getting booster jobs and getting
vaccinations thank you
okay thank you chair um i think the main
message as julia said is to still
continue to encourage everybody to
access their first house if they haven't
their second dose and when eligible
their uh booster but i'll come on to
that so
um you will all have seen of course um
the the news over the weekend and um
there have been a number of national and
regional uh meetings this week which
i've attended um it with regard to the
new variant and the next phase of the
vaccination program so the nhs is now
having to work at pace and to respond to
the new variant and put in place the
next phase of the what's been a really
successful vaccination program but this
is potentially going to be the the most
kind of complex phase
so following updated guidance from jcvi
and that updated guidance is um fourfold
so um anybody over 18 being able to
access their booster vaccination the
time between second dose and booster
being reduced from six months to three
months uh second dose availability for
healthy 12 to 15 year olds and also
immunocompromised people and being
offered a fourth dose um three months
after their third dose so there's four
um changes to eligibility criteria i
must point out that none of those have
yet gone live so this is a change to
criteria but they have not yet been
operationalized and i'll come onto the
messaging shortly
um we are still awaiting guidance from
the nhs um in terms of how staff will
expand the booster program and from an
nhs perspective this will be expected
through gps and primary care networks
local pharmacies and hospital hubs to be
restored up and potentially as you
mentioned chair um additional um science
being able to express an interest in
providing the vaccination program that
guidance is awaited and the guidance
will also include um how booster jobs
will be given in priority order so that
most vulnerable people are protected
first and in line with um how the
vaccine program's been rolled out
previously um but whilst also increasing
capacity to vaccinate millions more
people and in a short amount of time and
of course through a system that's
already under significant pressure
so um the the detail is awaited the
messaging really for residents is that
the nhs will contact you when you are
due to book in for your lifesaving
booster vaccination and when you get the
call or the text it's vital that people
come forward as quickly as possible as i
say the the enhanced and changed
eligibility is not yet
enforced so we would ask as well that
you please um remind residents not
to yet if they're over 18 try and access
through the national booking line and as
that that offer is not yet um open and i
will of course confirm when it is
thank you uh rebecca any questions at
all for rebecca uh councillor acton
yeah it's just about the walking centers
because i know there are some in in the
area in trafford um
it's not working well uh the the people
sort of use that uh i know they have to
be eligible but uh
i i don't know how it actually works
but you know there's one near me and uh
i don't know how people can access it
except for just walking in
and that is how to access a walk-in so
yes every week we publish a list of our
vaccination clinics and that um includes
um the
first dose second dose and booster dose
and whether they are available via book
deployment only or walking so we do have
um walk-ins available um in trafford and
they are being utilized well
um the guidance at present is that
walk-ins um are not advised for booster
vaccinations it should be bookable and
it should be when when um you are
contacted however and we know that some
people are walking into um those for
booster and if eligible then the
providers are opportunity
opportunistically um delivering that
booster if eligible so um
the guidance says one thing but then
opportunistically that's that is
available so
but yeah walk so well utilized for
accessibility
yeah okay
thanks rebecca
are there any further questions at all
i don't see any thank you very much
rebecca again um so we'll move on to
while still waiting for uh kirsty uh
community engagement to welcome louise
wright louise
morning chair thank you and so in terms
of the community
community engagement update just to
reiterate really that the team will be
um supporting and helping get the
message out about the precautionary
approach that we're taking while we find
out more about the new variant we are
continuing with our progressing with our
winter engagement plan which was
developed in partnership with a range of
um community partners so i'll just give
a reminder of the five strands of that
plan and the work that's ongoing so the
first one is around the health messaging
and the call to action
excuse me
um so we now have winter packs with
leaflets and promotional items that
we're distributing at events so via
community partners such as our hubs
libraries and a number of groups we're
also working with our comms and partners
again just looking at
the digital content that we can be
displaying across the borough to help
share those those key messages
and also just sort of giving you know
the general health messaging as well for
winter around keeping warm mental health
staying active um and some of the key
information about community hubs
in terms of the second strum we're
continuing to work with and build on our
networks so we've had some great
sessions with our community champions
and volunteers just understanding with
them how we can be more effective around
our messaging and comms we are
continuing to promote the vaccine
confidence work and understand where
this hesitancy so
um we're working with the the data
analysts and to look at that
unvaccinated um population group where
we've done some questionnaires and
surveys so that's currently being
analyzed and we have the team busy sort
of out attending a number of different
events that are already happening and we
have also been delivering a number of
focus sessions
with our
chair we have a problem with the
[Music]
louise appears to have frozen doesn't
she yes yes she does um
whilst we're waiting to get her back in
i have do have a an issue to raise of
course been in the situation where um
it is mandatory to wear a mask in
enclosed spaces shops public transport
are we as a council going to step up
enforcement
of this to assist
our colleagues in the police
uh i know we used to have helen grant
here are we going to invite them back to
the next meeting to tell us
what steps are being taken by the
council
to enforce to to to advise and and
visits made to premises because of
course we've got the trafford center and
i know the trafford center
have actually published how they're
going to enforce mass work but that is a
a huge issue for us particularly up to
christmas which is not just attractive
people from traffording they're coming
from all over the northwest and beyond
to to pack in there so i'm just
wondering if we need to be considering
now bringing um
helen back to the meeting uh for the
next meeting
any views
julian could be really helpful to get um
her perspective um in terms of
enforcement and i absolutely agree with
you um you know um we have these
enhanced measures for a temporary period
while we're finding out more about the
new variant um we we have reviewed our
um
variance uh of concern plan um
and i think you know we certainly have a
role in supporting uh enforcement of
these new measures at a time when we can
expect some of those spaces to be really
quite busy and crowded um so i'll
certainly uh invite her to join the next
meeting if there's an agreement that
would be helpful what i will do jilla is
i will write to helen today
uh an email and copy you in invite me to
the next meeting and asking it to to to
bring forward what plans we've got to to
support that the temporary enforcement
measures if that everyone is in
agreement with that
great louise can we go back to you now
you froze before
can you hear me louise
i'll try to um and mute louise from my
side chair see what it works
okay
um louise perhaps
would you like to use the chat to let us
know whether um your connection
um what will happen what happens to you
with your connection
i think when she was cut off she was
just telling us about the focus groups
that they've been uh delivering and i
know that they've delivered some this
week in the uh north and central um
neighborhoods and that's been
really insightful
in terms of people's
early concerns about the omicron variant
and people
expressing their worries about vaccine
effectiveness and
and what implications this this might
have so it's really valuable for us to
um have
planned those focus groups
and that we're able to draw on that
insight in an incredibly timely uh
timely way um i don't think she got on
to mentioning a piece of school's work
that the team are planning at the moment
so i can just tell you briefly about
that if it would be helpful
so this is a a model that tame sight
have used and that we are
also offering um secondary schools um
can submit an expression of interest to
receive receive some funding um for an
arts arts-based project
and that's an opportunity for young
people to use the arts to express
um their views and experiences of living
through the pandemic
and so the community engagement team are
facilitating uh that
and um and they're also really happiness
i hope you have picked up the thread at
the right point
so louise i've just um talked about the
school's program are you there
with us
we may have lost her again i was just
going to say that the community
engagement team were obviously also
helping us to get that message out
because the reach they have into
communities about the current enhanced
measures um so
hopefully that was everything she was
going to cover
thanks julia i've got a question from
councillor blackburn
thank you chairman uh when you sort of
um
mentioned enforcement a few minutes ago
um in the press and i've noticed that
one or two supermarkets are saying that
they're not willing to
um to confront any shoppers about not
wearing any any masks now obviously
these are you know the national um
supermarkets then you know this this
could have have a real
knock on effect you know with to do you
know with
you know the the fact that we're all
sort of now trying to
prevent anything nasty happening over
the winter over above what's already
happening
and so
our our enforcement team is aren't going
to be able to do anything about those
are they
well i mean i think the the issue is is
that it's it's a question of
environmental health officers visiting
premises that maybe that's a problem
particularly the trafford center
and the trafford center's private
property i would argue that if you're
not going to prepare to wear a mask
they've got the right to refuse entry
um
but that's a matter for the trapper
center management but i think generally
it's about as giving advice to um
uh to to supermarkets to shops to to uh
uh you know
across the beast uh to encourage them to
uh you know
to just encourage people to to wear a
mask um and actually i might have to say
that in the last
it's only just been the last 24 hours
but i was in sale yesterday
and there was a take-up in you know very
few problems people were wearing masks
in shops and that's a good thing it's a
good sign
thank you
understand where you're coming from yeah
i think i think it was more that that
certain supermarkets were saying that
they didn't want to put their staff
in any position of
of any danger and any any any shopping
making threats against them that that
was just you know just something i just
wanted to bring up
and nobody does it and we don't want to
see that sort of behavior and and i
think it's
what they're saying is if you if you
don't wear a mask please can you prove
give us proof that you don't that you're
exempt but there will be people that
deliberately won't wear a mask you're
absolutely right councillor blackburn
um
now then let me have a look um i did see
um
i did see louise back but she's gone
again
um
kirsty
shall we move on to kirstick welcome
kirsty this morning outbreak contact
tracing and outbreak management
yes thank you chair
and so
update today in terms of
skills and complex settings first of all
we have uh 30
37 primary schools
where there are currently colby cases
um across trafford so we've got eight of
those primary schools that are currently
meeting
outbreak thresholds
we continue to work with them within the
frame the contingency framework that we
have
and so we are seeing increased activity
across schools
and on the flip side of that we have
just 13 high schools that have currently
have cases
um but numbers remain low in our
secondary schools at present and we've
got no secondary schools that are
meeting those outbreak thresholds
so we have got we are seeing a big
difference in case numbers across our
primary schools and our high schools
so we continue with the risk assessments
with schools and we continue with our
outbreak meetings
and putting any enhanced measures in
place for 10 days with a view to um the
priorities keeping children in school
and having face-to-face education
um with with mitigation measures
continuing to run um regular q a
sessions with our schools and update
them on any uh guidance or any updates
happening nationally or locally
and and continuing to develop our
processes and systems for ease of access
of reporting
and schools reporting to us
we don't have any care room outbreaks at
present which is really positive
workplace and events we're seeing
minimal activity as usual in our
workplaces so that tends to
um it's remaining low we've maybe have
um two settings with it in an outbreak
situation where we providing them advice
and guidance
and our events that we still have low
numbers um in terms of the proportions
of people that attend
and then finally on our locally
supported contact racing so those not
reached by the national team we follow
them up locally that remains really
really good so um last week we
successfully followed up 88 of our local
cases um with full completion of 74 and
we're finding our residents have been
really engaged in our locally contact
racing so we just wanted to thank our
residents for that and providing the the
right information at the right time
and so we have a good success rate
across gm um for our local contact
racing and we also continue to offer
support to people to
self-isolate whether that be with food
shopping
loneliness just engagement with people
and
everyone receives a follow-up call to
offer them support to isolate
and that's it from me chair thank you
thank you kirsty
any questions for kirsty at all
i don't see and it was thank you for
joining the meeting because i understand
you've been busy with an outbreak
meeting this morning so um yeah sorry in
the delay well i know i know the primary
score i'm sure they've got an outbreak
at the moment and and i know that i can
speak as a chair of governors they're
very very pleased with the support that
they get from the council and from
yourselves
thank you um
jilla you've got your hand up
i think just to build on what you were
saying i mean our outbreak uh team are
amazing and they know our settings
really well now and what i think that
means is that they're able to
um use soft intelligence and they will
notice anything unusual in the pattern
or the spread of uh kovid and i think
that will help you know alongside um the
sequencing and everything that ux are
doing um uh to uh
to to pick up any uh cases of the new
variant actually we spot things locally
in terms of differences in pattern and
behavior of covid and um because of our
experience we're really good at that now
thank you thank you gina any further
questions at all
i don't have any other business uh for
this meeting which means we've raced
through the meeting in about
40 minutes this morning
can i thank you all for your attendance
um and um
kind of just
wanted to thank all of our environmental
health all of our public health teams
the community engagement team for the
work that they're doing right across
trafford um so far there's no army
cronin variant in trafford
we wait to see if it doesn't arrive but
in the meantime the message is out that
it's still there it's not gone away it's
about
keeping your hands washed it's about
wearing that face mask and and being
careful with your contacts uh but thank
you all and our next meeting is going to
be on the 15th of december
and i'll see you all then
thank you very much everybody
thank